y nos preguntan cuántos palillos serán
necesarios para formar la quincuagésima
figura en esta sucesión y aquí ya nos
dibujaron los primeros cuatro términos
este es el primero el segundo el tercero
y el cuarto la sucesión obviamente
continúa lo que nosotros queremos saber
es cuántos palillos tiene la figura que
estaría en el lugar 50 así que empecemos
analizando qué pasa en esta primera
figura en esta primera figura tengo un
palillo dos palillos tres bolillos
cuatro polillas cinco palillos y seis
palillos así que hay seis palillos bien
y ahora en la segunda que pasa pues para
empezar tengo una copia de la primera
figura esta primera casa la podría
pensar como una copia de la primera
figura de modo que tengo los seis
palillos de la primera 12
1 2 3 4 5 6 claro y adicionalmente tengo
otros 5 palillos noten que ya no tuve
que construir por así decirlo una pared
izquierda porque ya podía usar la
derecha de la primera casa así que esto
lo podría pensar como los 6 palillos de
la primera figura más los 5 palillos
de esta segunda casita y eso me da un
total de 11 palillos en esta figura para
la tercera de nuevo tengo
una copia de la figura número 2 y aquí
tengo los 11 palillos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11
y acá tengo otros 5 palillos adicionales
y nuevamente no tuve que construir la
pared izquierda de la última casita de
la 'roja' entonces tengo 11 palillos de
la figura número 2 +
5 palillos adicionales
11 5 palillos y eso me da el gran total
de 16 palillos así que cada vez que
agregó una casita cada vez que avanzó en
la sucesión lo que está pasando es que
le estoy sumando cinco el número de
palillos anterior es decir el término 4
sería
16 + 5 que sería 21 y ustedes pueden
secar eso bien entonces volvamos a la
pregunta de cuántos palillos se requiere
si yo estoy en el enésimo termino en el
enésimo termino
enésimo término de la sucesión
o sea o en la enésima figura
entonces
yo estoy en el n menos uno más un
término
ok porque n es igual a n 11 y porque
esto es útil pues ahora puedo decir que
si por ejemplo estoy en la figura 2
entonces estoy en la figura 1 más 1 o si
estoy en la figura 3 estoy en la figura
2 más 1 lo interesante aquí es que yo
podría escribir una fórmula para el
número de palillos número de palillos en
la enésima figura
en palillos
cuántas va a ser pues tengo los seis
bolillas de la primera figura
y por cada término que haya avanzado
después de la primera figura tengo que
sumar 5 palillos así que voy a sumar 5
por n menos 1 gay porque no tengo que
volver a contar la primera figura esa ya
la tengo entonces esta es una fórmula
para el número de palillos o quizás
quizás también le sirva a pensarlo este
modo podría imaginar que tengo una
figura digamos la figura 0 o el término
0 en mi sucesión y el término 0 solo
consiste en un palillo es la pared
izquierda por así si lo podría pensar en
esta pared como esta de modo que si lo
pienso así en la enésima figura el
número de palillos en la enésima figura
en palillos
la enésima figura
encima
figura
cuántos van a ser pues tengo un palillo
de la figura cero y ahora sí ya que
obtengo la pared a izquierda no la tengo
que construir en el término 1 ni en el
término 2 ni en el término 3 porque ya
la tengo en el término 0 entonces ahora
sólo voy a agregar 5 palillos ahora sí
por cada etapa en la que esté ya no
necesito n menos 1 sino ahora
simplemente necesito 5 por n veamos si
esto funciona digamos que estoy en el
paso 4 tengo uno más cuatro por cinco
que es uno más 20 que es 21 que es
precisamente esto y coincide también con
esta fórmula 6 más 5 por 4 menos 14
menos 1 es 3 por 5 es 15 6 es 21 de
hecho estas dos fórmulas son
equivalentes pero bueno contestemos la
pregunta cuántos palillos se requieren
para la figura 50
figura
la quincuagésima figura pues voy a tener
uno más
simplemente sustituyó n igual a 50 así
que uno más 50 por 5 y cuánto es esto 50
por 5 es 250 más uno sería
251 y no importa qué fórmula usen de
hecho vamos a ver que esta fórmula se
reduce a esta y el modo de hacerlo pues
simplemente va a ser
vamos a expandir esto voy a distribuir
el 5 y voy a escribir esto como 6 más 5
por n menos 5 ahora 65 es simplemente 1
y tengo este 5 n así que esta fórmula y
esta son la misma pero esta era ésta así
que las dos fórmulas coinciden no
importa cómo lo hagan